this weekend Prince Harry will marry
Megan Merkel in a wedding that's going
to be a first for the royal family I'm
not talking about Megan's racial
heritage her nationality or her
religious education I'm talking about
the fact she's a feminist it's one of
the many things young women and men I've
been speaking to find inspiring about
her alongside of course the fact that
she's built her own career based on
talent becoming a successful actor in
suits she's used her disability as a
platform for activism and has pursued
her passions in a lifestyle blog in
short she's exactly the kind of woman so
many others aspire to be I say has the
reality is since announcing her
engagement Megan stop doing every one of
those things early alarming indications
are that she's preparing to be a
traditional royal wife performing
charity not activism losing so much of
the individuality that made her special
that would be so out of sync with what
people want and it would just be wrong
agree with much of what you say but you
say traditional royal wife or have we
seen so far a traditional royal wedding
not in the least
I mean the evidence is is that you're
worried that she's going to be crushed
by the firm and that she's going to be
sort of silenced I'm not sure I mean I
think everything's up for grabs right
now I have no idea what's going to
happen on Saturday evening about the
chaos of The Rime talking about the
cluster shambles of the red royal
wedding prep that we've seen and and the
failure of all the palaces to get a grip
on the fact that the de Markel's are
freelancing all over the shop but let's
leave that aside you're right she's the
last thing that Megan Markel said was
women need to have a vote have a voice
they have to be empowered to use them
since she said that we have heard
nothing now it remains to be seen
whether she will hit the ground running
and be an advocate and an activist for
all the charities that she's espoused so
brilliantly in her career to date or
whether she will just be a fast breeder
royal baby machine er there
baby every minute you know when the
Middletons are around I just think it's
too soon to tell
honestly I I feel that we're in really
uncertain waters I guess she's changing
the game I think we have an idea of what
kind of person she is from what she's
done in the past but the question for me
is will the palace will the monarchy be
with it enough to recognize that
allowing her to be herself would be an
asset for me I just want to show you
what one royal biographer thinks about
her potential impact with Meghan we've
got someone who is mixed-race who's a
career woman who's a divorcee who's
American who comes from a broken home
these are all she's more representative
of our society today then the you know
the the blonde daughter of an aristocrat
ever could be and you can see more of
that on Harry Meghan a love story which
is on Sky News now very bad you played
that in because it completely destroys
your argument with the reasons that we
went through that she's been married
before that she's mixed race whatever it
might be I mean we are to about the
British royal family are we because it
just doesn't resonate with me at all let
me show you a picture of Her Majesty the
Queen we are saying that these
traditional royal wives are they they
sort of stand back and then they don't
pursue fairness can I take you back to
before you were even thought of her
before your father was thought of the
nineteen forties here's Her Majesty the
Queen as of course princess ylim as a
truck mechanic it's a land hold on a
second it speaks to it speaks to what
she did so you can even put that in your
truck and smoke it and at the same time
you talk about Princess Diana you said
about that ended well hold on hold on
not taking up certain causes she was the
first person to make physical contact
with someone who had a you know she went
into those mines she took one load of
unfashionable causes for somebody like
Megan local to look at Princess Diana
that is an attractive model as to how
what you will expect our work it's no I
listen I grew up watching yes and she
paid the price that's what we all saw
she paid the price for trying to break
the mold of being a traditional role
that miserably are not happy in her
marriage I think we're missing a point
in our massive pointy well before
Harry's obviously happy well for himself
he's brought to the table the coins
bending over backwards to accommodate
even paying for and turning up what she
didn't turn up the Charles his gaffe
when he was getting married because he
was remarried George's Chapel for
Charles and Camilla though she declined
that offer from the back of the
opposition and the church okay okay and
I wish them all the very best thinking
about feminism and females women's
voices let's hear what Meghan has to say
for herself about herself
shall we we've got that in my song right
I think what's been really exciting as
we talk about the transition of this out
of my career but into the role is that
as you said the causes that have been
very important to me I can focus even
more energy on because very early out of
the gate I think you realize once you
have access or a voice that people are
willing to listen to with that comes a
lot of responsibility which I take
seriously and at the same time I think
in these beginning few months and now
being boots on the ground in the UK I'm
excited to just really get to know more
about the different communities here
smaller organizations we're working on
the same causes that I've always been
passionate about under this umbrella
well I didn't see how you say about
having having beaten Harry and and Megan
to being in a mixed race relationship
with an American I did I got there first
but what I'm really worried eyes that
people make her race the subject of
conversation and it isn't just what we
typically know of in terms of racism she
is simultaneously too white for people
that insist that she isn't authentically
black and too black for others who are
worried that the royal
is somehow being hijacked by some
foreign invasion let me quote to you
professor Andrews from Birmingham
University who is teaching Britain's
first Black Studies course and he's
called her a token and I think actually
before I was surprising he went down
this line what actually I'm not talking
about her time talking about how
feminism and now you're bringing I know
what I'm criticizing those who are doing
so and I think that whether whether it's
dr. Andrews is saying that she's - she's
she's basically a token and it is there
simply to act as as window dressing he
said when you have symbols that make it
look like things have changed and we
celebrate it that does more damage than
it could ever do good of the fact that
racism in the UK is not a problem that
will be sold on why are you defending
this I don't believe it I don't know sir
why are you defending this no one should
be called a tokens it's simply for
existing George Georgia Chambers has
said she's a journalist she said she did
use words okay nice Georgia chambers
said she could pass as white and I'm
just I'm just astounded that people that
talk about equality when finally we
achieve a symbol of precisely one it
said and we saw in that video a symbol
of modern Britain they want to drag it
down they want to pull it down and
complain alright if you're dragging it
down we're gonna lift you back up have a
look at this is another American
african-american woman who is marrying a
white British man this Saturday
expressing her feelings about the wrong
wedding I think what Megan brings to
tables a little bit different is the
element of it's going to be
international wedding is interracial
wedding she's quite open about and very
proud about the fact that she's a
mixed-race I think that only is going to
be beneficial because I'm an interracial
relationship and bringing that to the
foreground into the mainstream that's
only gonna hopefully be have a positive
impact and I think she's handling it
with the elegance and grace
that's lovely I think a lot of people
are focusing on the positive of this I
think for many reasons people relate to
mega and there we have the highest rate
of interracial relationships in the
Western world there are many people
looking at that couple who can
personally relate
she's a woman that I think young women
aspire to be passionate
so I just why we focusing on that the
question is focus so more important
question is not what gay and a Andrew
says but whether the monarchy are ready
to let a young women like Meghan come in
and thrive and not crush her
individuality and I really hope that
they are I think they're already doing
so the Queen's like the sails back down
to stuff she's accommodating it she's
paying for it all right
now we all know that things move on in
time and I think that they realized now
that these these are the people that are
taking the royal family forward and so
we've got a rubble these people that
they're doing it for us now and so I
don't believe that she'll be dragged
into any sort like that debacle I think
it's all about what partly what Meghan
wants if she's going into this she's
ended her career on on the American TV
where she was starring in the top rated
show suits maybe she regards this as the
greatest part she will ever play and
this is the one she actually wants to do
and we have to the other thing we have
to look at is if the royal if the royal
households don't want to have another
failed royal marriage on their hands
they have got to let Megan be Megan it
may have got to allow her some
self-determination in what she does from
Saturday onwards good moment I'd say I
met her in Canada a week before this was
announced and we shared a panel together
and I said sorry so what do you do she
said I'm in some TV program called Susan
was that I said I'm not I mean
[Laughter]